[Music]
rebeccablack maybe most well-known for
her 2011 viral hit song and video Friday
[Music]
of course it's become a cult classic but
in 2020 Rebecca is making headlines for
all the right reasons earlier this year
Rebecca candidly discussed the
depression that she went through as a
teenager being subjected to all the
online bullying and now in a brand new
interview Rebecca has said she
identifies as queer I mean I guess the
best way everyday it's like Concordia
every day I it's something that over the
past few years I've obviously been
having a lot of conversations with
myself a lot but and with you know like
you guys and my friends and my family
and stuff but I think leanness gay yeah
I am but I think to me the word queer
feels really nice I have dated both I
dated a lot of different types of people
and like I just don't really know what
the future holds in some days I feel a
little bit more on the gay side than
that there is during the interview
Rebecca makes it clear that she is not
ready to date I just got out of a
relationship with a girl that was a
pretty long relationship so yes I will
cry for the break-up I think that's also
actually a funny thing that might come
out of this quarantine I think a lot of
people might come out I don't really
want to date right now with the
relationship that I have just had it's
like nothing because there wasn't
anything that like what I mean I love
this person so much still so we're very
much trying to like support it's a weird
time so we're trying to be there for
each other like through it in that
without but also like in a different way
than being in a relationship if that
makes sense I don't know I honestly
can't imagine how difficult it was to be
a teenager subjected to that kind of
online bullying she is a strong woman
and I love that she is continuing with
her muse
late last year should release the song
and video sweetheart
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think of Rebecca black
coming out as queer do you think people
were way too harsh on Rebecca for Friday
have you ever been bullied how did you
overcome it let me know in the comments
below oh hey there if you want more
LGBTQ news and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos